la semaine dernière canal + diffusé un
documentaire exclusif sur le sort des
femmes journalistes dans l'univers du
sport un univers parfois machi sur
lequel témoigné plusieurs professionnels
nous sommes des femmes nous sommes des
journalistes
mais je ne suis pas une [ __ ] dans ce
documentaire and extrait coupé diffusé
le lendemain dans tpm paix impliqués
pierre ménès une séquence dans laquelle
la journaliste marie portolano confronté
le journaliste à une action commise en
2016 sur le plateau du canal football
club
lorsqu'il avait soulevé la jupe de la
journaliste hors antenne ça par exemple
parce que je leur ferai aujourd'hui oui
soulever la jupe de quelqu'un comme ça
s'il s'était exprimé une première fois
sur notre plateau pierre ménès a
renouvelé ses excuses sur twitter cette
fois ci en s'adressant à toutes les
femmes qu'il a pu blesser ou avec
lesquels il a pu avoir un comportement
inapproprié
je tenais à tous vous dire que je
regrette sans aucune ambiguïté tous ces
gestes du passé qui ne se justifient
aucunement je réitère mes regrets et mes
excuses les plus sincères les excuses
franches que certains attendaient alors
êtes vous convaincu par les excuses de
pierre ménès alors pour guillaume bah en
fait il n'a pas le choix et là il s'est
fait défoncer par le tribunal médiatique
depuis le début ses excuses ici parce
qu'ils étaient quand même excusé faut
pas l'oublier sur ce plateau
elles n'ont pas été jugé assez plate
entre uni mais est pas est assez
conséquent donc il est obligé de se ré
excusé d'autant plus qu'il a des yeux
quelques sanctions professionnellement
donc il n'a pas le choix la fifa la
examen usa je suis entièrement d'accord
avec guillaume et c'est justement pour
ça que ça me gêne parce que je trouve
qui s'aplatit inutilement ce qui le
détestaient vont continuer à le détester
et ceux qui l'avaient déjà excusé n'ont
pas besoin de ces excuses là donc moi je
trouve que c'est une humiliation qui
s'inflige et qui ne changera rien
n'arrête bien sûr vous allez pouvoir est
pour les jeunes filles quand même des
alliés forts wave y allez un petit peu
fort sur le sur l'humiliation vigiles
moi ce qui me gêne c'est que j'ai
l'impression que c'est de la
communication géré par une cellule de
crise et que je trouve dans là c'est
plus la communication de ce père lui de
plus gérer là c'est lui qui l'a fait
seul je vous le dis mais oui je vous lis
non mais la csu cetur voilà je vous dis
franchement belgique est on pense à moi
je trouve qu'effectivement la grosse
erreur qui l'a fait qu'il a fait sur le
plateau et mais en fait c'est pas
tellement d'avoir expliqué d'avoir des
bois je leur ferai c'est à l'insee s'est
lui comme comme on l'a connu mais le
fait d'être venu sur le plateau nous
dire ce qu'il a dit effectivement il
court après ça et maintenant c'est très
compliqué parce qu'effectivement il ya
ya ya le jeu vif aquila qui l'a puni et
maintenant les gens lui envoyer c'est de
pire en pire et puis va parler oui
danisco non mais je suis chez moi je
non j'ai pas compris ce que disait matin
parce que shaw qui est permanente et
comprend jamais ce que dit moi ça va
j'ai bien compris benjamin parce qu'en
fait il a été nommé et bascharage pense
qu'il est dans le brouillard
la nouvelle qui dans un tunnel
s'adressant à des victimes attention il
ya des victimes quoi nasa a été
courageux de venir s'expliquer sur le
plateau je redis attention à quelque
chose aussi c'est que on a montré des
boues des boutabout d'image qui datait
de 2007 ça n'excuse rien et le mec tout
d'un coup il se prend tout dans la tête
comme ça un jour en se levant le matin
donc il a été sur la défensive il était
très mal à l'aise et je pense que c'est
sur ce plateau qu'il a pris conscience
des choses et je pense que là cette fois
ci et s'est excusé en parlant vraiment
avec son coeur qui revenant de vivre une
semaine difficile
j'ai été entendu là tu étais pas
convaincu la première fois par les
excuses je suis encore moins parler
deuxième j'ai l'impression en fait qui
s'excuse en fonction de ce qu'il lit sur
les réseaux sociaux mais c'est mon avis
nico et quand tu viens tu excusé en
disant voilà je reconnais évidemment oui
mais en même temps aujourd'hui on ne
peut plus rien dire et on ne peut plus
rien faire c'est ça que moi j'ai trouvé
regrettable et qui me gêne et je ne
pense pas les esclaves
hilali perdu s'excuser et il a tout
perdu isabelle ah oui moi je trouve
qu'il a énormément perdu
et je vous dis une fois de plus qu'on
les sanctionne je le comprends mais
beaucoup leur sanctionné par trous plus
que par conviction donc des réactions
commercial de verdi moi je crois que
permanence essaie de sauver sa peau et
on le comprend tout à fait et on vient
une période extrêmement douloureux est
ce qu'il a fait lui un
bernard montiel un cas que j'ai fait
vous allez me paraît que vous avez
j'aime ici je vais votre peau quand vous
étiez cuir tf1 vous êtes pareils je suis
parti j'ai pas eu peur je leur ai dit ce
que je pensais je suis parti j'ai rien
demandé paname damn it et que dalle rien
n'est fait alors j'aurais pu demander
j'ai rien demandé
avec ce que vous disiez à berne alliés
pendant des années les indemnités ça va
c'est vrai que c'était bien payé mais
c'est elle et surtout plaidé
une émission qui plaisait qui était sage
à léogâne je disais que le soldat pierre
ménès et tente de sauver sa peau en le
comprends mais là on vit une période
extrêmement douloureuse de de délation
la parole s'est libérée et tant mieux
mais alors là maintenant tout le monde
en prend plein la tronche quoi